bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'apple du port jack du câble ait ni
l'adaptateur lightning jaqee encore
présents dans les boîtes depuis l'iphone
7 va disparaître a priori dès cette
année et ça pour moi ça fait vachement
de peine on y va
alors la stratégie elle est triple la
stratégie elle est vraiment reid pour
apple la toute première chose c'est
effectivement d'économiser sur les
accessoires présent dans la boîte va
leur coûter beaucoup moins cher
le deuxième truc c'est que vous allez
acheter vous un accessoire si vous
voulez vous toujours sereine aux
adaptateurs lightning vers jack
il va falloir vous le payez à 9 euros 1
sur le site d'apple et le troisième
point c'est qu'ils vont faire vendre des
casques bluetooth la source note des
analystes de barclays qui reprennent les
analyses de mines chico michiko qui
bosse pour kg sécurities je sais c'est
des analyses qui parle des analystes qui
part des analystes mais ça ça paraît
assez logique parce qu'on voit qu'apple
est dans cette décision de supprimer le
port jack et de lui dire à 2 c'est clair
qu'à terme le progrès claude aura plus
mais il ya encore beaucoup de produits
qui sont commercialisés avec des ports
jack et ça c'est quand même relativement
dommage mais on va faire un petit calcul
tout bête et vous allez voir que le truc
est hyper bien pensée de la part d'apple
si c'est confirmé
toujours on va regarder les petites
pincettes mais de toute façon même si ça
arrive pas cette année ça finira par
arriver
on voit que le port jack disparaît des
produits l'accessoire forcément
disparaître et il ya un vrai calcul
derrière il ya un vrai intérêt et vous
allez voir qu'au final en faisant
disparaître l'accessoire apple va
vraiment gagner beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent alors on y va on va
partir sur le principe que apple sort
sain un de ses nouveaux smartphones va
envahir qu'ils en vendent 20 millions 20
millions je sais c'est ridicule parce
que au final apple vend beaucoup plus
mais on va y avait un million parce que
on va rester dans des proportions
raisonnables vraiment point la joue un
peu petit bras
donc on va imaginer cet accessoire port
jack lightning coût deux fois à lille il
est vendu 9 euros pour moi très
clairement il faut fabriquer en chine
c'est un truc de leur coûtait quoi en
prix de revient par pièce à l'échellle
hyper généreux je veux dire 1 euros en
prix de revient par pièce je pense que
c'est quand même beaucoup moins mais bon
allez on va dire un euro on va dire x 9
au prix de vente ça me paraît déjà quand
même avec des collègues de dingue mais
bon on n'en parlons pas donc au final ce
qu'ils vont faire c'est que sur 20
millions sur 20 millions d'exemplaires
vendus
vous enlevez un euro à chaque fois en
termes de coûts de production au final
vous économisez quand même 20 millions
c'est 20 millions que vous ne dépensez
pas ensuite on va dire que sur ces 20
millions de smartphones vendus
il va y avoir quoi elle est un quart des
personnes qui vont dire
m j'ai un casque avec un port jack
j'aimerais bien pouvoir l'utiliser dans
mon iphone va tiens je vais me l'acheter
un quart de personnes qui vont acheter
la tâte heures lightning vers port jack
au final ils vont dire bon allez 9 euros
c'est quoi j'ai acheté un iphone qui
coûte déjà 600 700 800 900 mille euros
je peux racheté 9 euros de plus à la
commande
c'est pas bien grave on s'en tape assez
et même à la limite ça paraît presque
gratuit à côté du prix d'achat d'un
iphone donc vous allez avoir à lens dit
un quart de personnes jours toutes
proportions gardées un quart de ses 20
millions ça nous fait 5 millions de
personnes qui vont l'acheter à 9 euros
donc je vous laisserai à petit calcul ça
nous fait quand même un bénéfice pour un
peu lent plus de 45 millions d'euros
d'un côté en n'étant pas le produit ils
vont économiser 20 millions de notre
côté sur ce qu'arthur sur ces 20
millions ils vont gagner 45 millions ce
qui fait que en réalité par rapport à
l'exercice de l'aide avant qu'ils vont
gagner 65 millions alors je sais ils
vont pas embaucher 65 millions mais si
vous regardez par rapport aux chiffres
de l'année d'avant où il incluait
directement cette douleur coûté un euro
là ils vont en vendre peut-être 5
millions à 9 euros ils vont
effectivement faire plus 65 millions au
niveau de l'exercice comptable juste sur
cette ligne a avec ce petit adaptateur
mais attendez ça s'arrête pas là là
effectivement ça paraîtrait encore un
petit peu simpliste ça va beaucoup plus
loin parce que apple fabrique aussi des
casques ils ont racheté beats donc ils
ont les casques beats si vous dites
bhatia main pour le coup puisque péter
et mon casque avec matrix jack peuvent
acheter un casque est directement
bluetooth et pourquoi pas un casque
vendus par apple
un casque beats ça pourrait être aussi
intéressant même si toutes les ventes
des casques bluetooth non pas se tourner
vers un peu il va le casque beats
néanmoins apple va en vendre pas mal là
dedans
autre économie c'est l'économie de
logistique puisque il ya un mouvement
afférents - lors de la fabrication lors
de la production des produits
ça va leur coûter forcément un petit peu
moins cher aussi à produire et autre
point qui est aussi très intéressant
pour apple tous ceux qui fabriquent des
casques avec des ports jack pourrait
mettre directement à l'intérieur un
adaptateur jack vers lightning
puisqu'apple ne le fait pas les
fabricants de casques pourrait faire et
il faut savoir qu'apple est propriétaire
du cadre du port lightning donc dès lors
que vous insérez un port de lightning
dans 20 de vos produits
vous devez
payer c'est le meilleur iphone vous le
payez et vous donnez des royalties
directement apple ce qui fait que si les
fabricants de casques décide de rajouter
ce petit produit apple va encaisser
aussi de l'autre côté et on peut aussi
imaginer que les fabricants qu'ils ne
fassent que dépend directement en
lightning pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ça
peut aussi être en tout cas tant et non
dans tous les cas dans tous les cas de
figure en supprimant ce petit adaptateur
directement de leur boîte apple va
gagner beaucoup d'argent et je pense
réellement ça sera pas un frein parce
que vous vous dites tiens je vais
acheter le nouvel iphone le nouvel
iphone 10 noeuds cette année by ap
adaptateur en battant pippa tant pis je
veux pas acheter l'iphone vous n'allez
pas vous dire que l'iphone il est génial
il me plaît il ya toutes les nouvelles
spécifications il ya nouveau fait ça il
dit à nouveau s'il est nouveau c'est le
truc ça me plaît ce produit sexy vous
n'allez pas vous dire maintenant je vais
pas l'acheter il n'ya pas l'adaptateur
port jack lightning non vous vous en
fichez dans le quart des cas vous allez
l'acheter ou allemand vous vous dites
à terme je vais renouveler mon casque
donc c'est une stratégie gagnante
apple même si effectivement le
consommateur va grincer des dents au
début au final ça va vraiment quelque
chose de gagnant gagnant
d'un point de vue monétaire pour eux
dites moi ce que vous en pensez ce que
vous pensez que cette stratégie est la
bonne est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ce que je viens de dire
vous marquez tout ça en commentaire
comme d'hab et a blessé des jolies
pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on va
rester on va parler toujours plus de
teck plein de choses qui arrivent plein
de surprises plein de nouveautés plein
d'exclus plein d'infos donc restez
connectés d'ici là soyez ça je vous
embrasse et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]